algorithms has been sort of like a
tremendously important throughout
computer science actually i remember the
first time was l cubed where they were
teaching it again and again in the
algorithms class at berkeley and
and
in daniele is has worked on both sides
both the algorithms for a lattice uh
like he has the
first exponential algorithm for cvp the
exact cpp
closest vector problem and the
cryptographic applications of it um you
know like sampling trapdoors uh for
lattices and so forth and daniella has
done this for many many years spanning
more than three decades and i'm
extremely uh especially proud that
daniela is actually my student
in the past i guess always a student
and i agreed to give this talk and i'm
incredibly grateful to him because he's
like an amazing expositor as well so
thank you
okay thank you for the introduction and
thank you for the invitation for having
me here is a great pleasure to talk here
at the symposium so i'll be talking
about fully homomorphic encryption
for the non-cryptographers well let me
first tell you briefly informally that
encryption traditionally is a tool that
can be used to encode messages
in a way that you can store them or
transmit them while protecting your
content so that unless
somebody knows your secret key the
content of the message is protected by
this encryption buyer
fully homologic encryption is an
enhanced form of encryption which allows
not only to secure restore and then
retrieve your data it allows to perform
computations on encrypted data without
decrypting it and in fact without even
knowing the decryption key now this is a
technology that opens a lot of doors to
potential applications so think of
using a lightweight device like your
laptop or a tablet
and keeping your data stored on the
cloud on some a big but untrusted server
you can still encrypt all your data keep
it securely stored and not only retrieve
it if you want to retrieve the old data
you can even get the cloud the server to
perform computations for you on the
encrypted data without
revealing any information about the data
itself and of course the result of the
computation would still be in encrypted
form it can be sent to you and you can
decrypt and read the final result
now so this is a very powerful tool
and let me start with a brief
outline i'm skipping a lot of things of
course but just to put this in a
historical context the problem of
whether this was possible at all was
posed a long time ago already in
1978 by rivest adelman and dertuzos they
posed these as a problem but without
having any solution to perform arbitrary
computations on encrypted data there
were some cryptosystems supporting some
very basic operations but when we talk
about fully homomorphic encryption the s
stands the fully stands for the ability
to perform
arbitrary computations either described
as boolean circuits or described as
arithmetic circuits or your favorite
programming model
now it was not until 2009
that the community somehow
made a big jump forward with a
breakthrough result of a craig gentry
that proposed the first candidate
solution to the problem to perform
arbitrary computations on encrypted data
and also introduced a bootstrapping
technique
that helped develop in the field and
come up with many other solutions to the
same problem
sorry
so only this problem the community the
cryptographic community started really
believing that it was possible to do
this
and two years later in another
fundamental step the brackets came by
contact and came up with the first solid
solution to this problem based on
standard lattice problems
standard the complexity assumptions on
lattices and i mean this work was
crystallized the following year in a
work by gentry balkesque in the
continent
in what is now called the bgv scheme
which is an efficiency improvement over
the original bd proposal and it is
fairly close to homomorphic to certain
form of homomorphic encryptions that are
still currently in use now what happened
from 2012 to 2022 in this last 10 years
so a lot of things happened so this was
just the beginning and there's been a
steady stream of works
improving fully homomorphic encryption
schemes which at first were purely
theoretical
constructs showing that something was
possible
into something that
is getting
closer and closer to being actually use
usable
and new schemes were proposed efficiency
improvements additional features so
there's been a driving uh
community of both theoreticians and more
applied people building libraries that
implement fully homomorphic encryption
and social
helium
and
so these are just examples there are
many libraries out there implementing
various forms or some
sub collection of the homogeneous
encryption schemes that have been
developed through the years
all of these schemes and the solutions
they're all based on lattices so the
same type of mathematical problems
already used by bgv and they all make
use of these bootstrapping
technique so this fundamental technique
introduced already back then in 2009 and
it is still a big component of any
solution that can perform arbitrary
computations
now uh
so all this activity during this last 10
years and it was a lucky coincidence
that this coincided with the 10 years of
life of the simon's institute here and
as already mentioned by rachel earlier
this morning there have been uh some a
lot of there's been a lot of activity at
the institute on lattice cryptography in
related areas so in 2015 we had a full
program on cryptography that included
the boot camp tutorials and workshops on
lattice cryptography and fully
homomorphic encryption
and in
2020 we had a full program just
dedicated to lattices not only for
cryptography also lattice algorithms and
lattice complexity and and this week is
actually the first week of the lapis
summer cluster that will go on until at
the end of
the end of june and it has been great
uh to yeah be able to call gather the
community of lattice cryptography fully
homophobic encryption and related area
and bring everybody together here at the
institute year after year
so let's get more technical so today i
want to talk about uh fully homophobic
encryption but without getting into the
technical details of the constructions
so i tried to
give
something that has some technicalities
but it's a fairly high level
so hopefully it won't be too too hard
just before lunch so i will first start
with a description with a more technical
description of the traditional
definition of the fully homomorphic
encryption this idea of being able to
compute unencrypted data
and then i will briefly very briefly
make the touring to lattice cryptography
to show what are the problems the
technical problems that need to be
solved when you want to do that we'll
see that the cipher texts are noisy and
this is the problem that was initially
solved using bootstrapping
and so the reason i'm talking about this
is because bootstrapping is still the
only way known to build these schemes
and there are some important open
problems related to it
so after that i will present a new
perspective on bootstrapping and the
definition of homomorphic encryption
which i think might may shed some
light on these problems and time
permitting which means i will probably
skip that because we are already a
little bit behind schedule
i may mention approximate encryption
approximate homomorphic encryption which
is another problem another variant of
homomorphic encryption that has been
receiving a lot of attention in the last
few years and it also raised some
interest in important definitional
problems
so let's start with simple encryption in
an encryption scheme we have a very
simple syntax we have a key generation
algorithm an encryption algorithm and a
decryption algorithm and you can use
this generation algorithm to produce a
pair of keys a public key and a secret
key now for the purpose of this talk the
distinction between public and secret is
not that important if you want you can
think of all algorithms being performed
using the secret key except for the
evaluation evaluation is something that
should be performed in a typical
application by an entrance server so
that should be a publicly computable
operation so in a start and encryption
scheme if you have a message m you
encrypt it and then you apply the
decryption algorithm you expect to find
exactly the message you started from
so homomorphic encryption
introduces a new algorithm into the
picture and evaluation algorithm that
takes as input a function a function
that you can think of as the description
of the program that you wanted to
compute on your data and the correctness
definition the correctness
condition associated to homomorphic
encryption is the following so if you
start from a message m and you encrypt
it to produce a ciphertext
then you apply this function this
evaluation function to evaluate the
function f homomorphically on this
ciphertext you will obtain one more
ciphertext
which when decrypted gives as a final
result exact exactly what you would
expect f m the result of performing the
computation in the clear without any
form of encryption
now this is the traditional definition
of what and how morphic encryption
scheme is is a good definition it
closely models what you want to do in an
application
and this was the initial goal of the
homomorphic encryption schemes
now let me tell you a few words just a
few words about lattices so in a lattice
crypto system
keys are vectors and here i will just
focus on using secret keys so the secret
key think of it as a vector with n
coordinates with n integer coordinates
and the way you use this vector s to
encrypt a message m is the following you
generate a random matrix a typically
with entries from some finite rings
integers modulo q for some not too large
q
you also generate a random noise vector
e and by noise i mean that this vector
is chosen at random
by the small coordinate so it could be
gaussian noise or uniform entries over a
small interval
and you encrypt the message m by
outputting this random matrix a and then
a vector b which is this expression here
given by a s
plus a scaled copy of the message m
times the scaling factor delta
perturbed by this noise vector e and
we'll see in a moment why you want to
scale the message m
now how do you decrypt this ciphertext
you can take this vector b so this is
the decryption algorithm you take a and
b b is this expression here right you
can first of all you can subtract a s
from it so you know a which is from here
you know s which is the secret key and
as you perform this subtraction you will
be left only with this component delta m
plus e
which when divided by delta will give
you exactly the message m
up to a small additive perturbation
which is the error vector divided by
delta so if delta is small enough if
delta is smaller than delta over 2 if if
e if the error e the noise is smaller
than delta over 2 then if you round this
vector to the closest integer so
component wise one coordinate at a time
you will remove the error and recover
the original the original message
now it's easy to see how this very
simple encryption scheme is also
homomorphic it's not fully homomorphic i
mean in fact you can make it into a
fully homomorphic scheme but here i'm
just showing you that it's a purse
addition so addition is almost trivial
so if you add up to ciphertext
ciphertext c0 that encrypts the message
m0 and a cypher text c1 that encrypts
the message m1
then when you adapt and ciphertext are
matrices so you just perform a normal
standard matrix addition and if you
factor out the s and delta you collect
the like terms you'll see that the sum
of two ciphertexts is an encryption of
m1 plus m0 with an error which is the
sum of e1 plus e0 so if the original
input noise was less than delta over 4
then the resulting cipher text is less
as an error which is less than delta
over 2 and you can decrypt the final
result now this very simple property
also highlights a limitation of this
type of cryptography errors build up so
the noise gets bigger so for example if
you perform three additions instead of
two then the error may become bigger
than delta over two and then decryption
may lead to the incorrect result so it's
a very limited form of homomorphism i
didn't show you how to do multiplication
but multiplication
as the same kind of issue and the error
grows even faster than by addition but
there is this fundamental difficulty of
error growing out of bound now this is
precisely what
gentry solved by introducing this
bootstrapping technique as a technique
to reduce the amount of noise in a
lattice-based ciphertext
and so this was done as follows so
assume that you have a schema that can
support operations but only up to a
certain point so it supports operations
of a certain size but then beyond that
the error may become too big and you
cannot keep computing you want to reduce
the amount of noise in this ciphertext
so what is suggested is to look at the
decryption function but so decryption
function takes a secret key and a
ciphertext usually we think of this as a
function described by the secret key
which operates on the ciphertext as an
input now we want to look at this by
reversing the role of the two inputs
think of decryption as a function that
is described by a ciphertext every
ciphertext describes a corresponding
function and the function takes its
input to the secret key and what it does
is just to decrypt the fix ciphertext
with that key now why is that
interesting it is interesting because it
gives you a way
to compute the identity function which
may seem trivial
but in a way that improves the quality
of the cipher text now using the
previous definition of
correctness that i gave before if you
evaluate
this function fc
on input and encryption of the secret
key so now the input is the to this
function is is the secret key we give it
to it in encrypted form and then we
evaluate this function f homomorphically
so this will still decrypt so it will
produce the result which is the original
ciphertext m the output of decryption it
will produce this value in encrypted
form because you are performing this
this computation harmonically but the
amount of noise in the final result does
not depend on the input cipher text it
is so the error in the in the input
cipher text is being so to speak
decrypted away and the noise in the
result of the evaluation only depends on
the noise in the encryption of the
evaluation key which is independent of
the computation that you performed
leading to the ciphertext c so this
allows to set up the parameters of
lattice cryptography appropriately in a
way that when you perform this the error
of your ciphertext goes down so you can
clean up a cypher text reduce the error
and keep computing for example you can
compute more and more additions
now these techniques require this
technique requires to publish an
encrypted copy of the secret key of a
scheme now encrypting a key
under itself or under the corresponding
public key so this is a classic problem
in cryptography it's called the circular
security problem so is an encryption
scheme still secure
even if you publish an encryption of the
secret key under itself and the standard
notion of security for encryption the
one that we know how to achieve
typically does not have this extra
feature
and addressing this circular security
issue which is required to apply uh
gentry's bootstrapping technique
is uh
it was a big open problem back in 2012
and is still today a big open problem in
the area how to deal with circular
security so what i want
to
do today is to look at the fully
homomorphic encryption problem in a way
that sort of sidesteps the circular
security is there a way to formulate i
mean resolving circular security would
be great of course
one way to address these is to prove
that any fully homomorphic encryption
scheme can be turned into a circular
secure one
and so we don't know what the answer is
but for the case of simple
non-homomorphic encryption scheme
there are some theoretical
evidence there is some theoretical
evidence showing that that's not
possible there are black box separations
showing that you cannot achieve circular
security in as a black box way but
perhaps you can still do it based on a
specific assumption like the learning
with error assumption used by
cryptography and a lattice-based
cryptography and and that's still an
open problem and so i want to take a
different look at the problem of
building a fully homomorphic encryption
and try to identify what is this
difficulty so in order to i look at a
different problem the problem of
composition consider the following
setting so you have a message m and you
wanted to perform a sequence of
computations on it the first you want to
apply a function f on it
to get a new message f of m and then you
wanted to apply another function g to f
of m to get g of f of f of n
now this is a
two-step computation and you can think
of doing it homomorphically you first
evaluate
a function f homomorphically on c0 c0 is
an encryption of the original input
message
then you run again the evaluation
algorithm to evaluate homomorphically
function g on c1 to get a ciphertext c2
and assuming that the skin that you're
using is an encryption scheme
which supports
according to the definition given the
homomorphic evaluation of bot f and g
can you conclude that the result if you
decrypt c2 you get the g of f of m you
get what you want
and the result is that the answer is
that that's not necessarily true so that
may not be the case and the reason is
technically if it is a lattice-based
solution
is because the error may get bigger and
then when you give it to g there or is
too big to perform the computation but
this scientist can be traced to the
definition in a way it is independent of
the mathematical problems which are used
underneath so the problem is the
following if you look at the definition
of
homomorphic encryption so we have this
picture we have a message m encrypted to
c0 you have right function f and we know
that this output c1 decrypts to f of m
now there is a mismatch between the
output guarantee
of this evaluation c1 decrypts to f of m
and the requirement on the input to
apply the homomorphic evolution of g
here you want f f of m to be encrypted
into c one you want the c one to be the
result of applying the encryption
algorithm going up rather than the
decryption algorithm and going down and
it's easy to convince yourself that
these are different properties so saying
that c1 is an encryption of m1 and send
that to c1 decrypts to n1 are different
properties and the first property
implies the second one that comes from
correctness it means that if you take a
message m you encrypt it and encrypt it
you get the same m but in the other
direction if you start from a cipher
text you apply the decryption algorithm
and then you encrypt it again and
typically you will end up with a
different cipher text if not just for
the fact that encryption is randomized
so you will not get the original value
so there is this mismatch of input and
output in the definition
which uh let me to propose a different
definition which is the following
something i like to call fully
composable homomorphic encryption or
composable fhe if you prefer
and this is the definition so i require
that for every ciphertext c
if you decrypt c
and then you apply the function f
you get the same result as first
evaluating the function f homologically
and then decrypting the result so it's
slightly different from what we had
before and notice in the previous
definition in the traditional definition
we are going up with the encryption
algorithm then we do homomorphic
violation and down and we ask this
diagram to commute here also we are
making a community requirement but what
we do is to always start from the
ciphertext and the properties are both
described in terms of the decryption
algorithm so if you decrypt an evaluate
f or evaluate f homomorphically and then
decrypt you should get the same result
so in some sense decryption commutes
with function evaluation
and the nice feature
is of this definition is that now you
have something composable if you perform
two computations in a sequence
first f and then g the output guarantee
matches the input requirement and you
can conclude that if your scheme is a
fully composable home of your encryption
scheme then you can do this now this is
a very powerful
property because it allows to instead of
fully typically refers to the fact that
you can compute the arbitrary programs
on encrypted data in fully homophobic
encryption here i'm just focusing on the
composability once you have
composibility you don't need to be able
to evaluate arbitrary programs you just
need to be able to evaluate any strike a
small instruction set the elementary
operations of your programming language
and then you can combine them any way
you want you can put them together to
put arbitrary programs together but
that's not required
to be analyzed in the context of the
definition
so this uh so let me skip this so it's
easy to see that one definition implies
the other one that is fully composable
is a strengthening of the previous
definition but let me skip that and jump
to the conclusion which is uh so you can
think of this definition as a different
way
to uh describe what is being achieved by
this bootstrapping technique so rather
than thinking of it as a lattice
specific method
to clean up ciphertext and remove errors
which are
details of lattice-based implementations
but things that don't even show up at
the definitional level there is no
reason why uh homomorphic encryption
schemes should have some kind of noise
in them
now you can think of the bootstrapping
technique as a method to transform a
scheme satisfying the traditional fully
homomorphic encryption definition where
you go up
right and down into the fully composable
definition the construction is exactly
the same so it is just the same as
gentry solution i'm just saying that i'm
changing the problem that is being
solved by the solution you can think of
it as a method to show that if you have
a scheme
satisfying the weaker traditional fhe
definition and the scheme is also
circular secure
then you can combine you can build a new
scheme which is a composable fha it's a
fully composable homomorphic encryption
scheme then the proof goes just as in
the previous case but now you can think
of the problem of solved by do strapping
not in terms of noise but as a problem
of connecting two different definitions
so
you can ask without talking about noise
or bootstrapping if fhe the traditional
definition is something that implies
the composable fhe is there a way to go
from one to the other one given an
arbitrary fully homomorphic encryption
scheme can you turn it into a fully
composable homomorphic encryption scheme
for a modest set of operations and say
additional multiplication that can be
used to implement the arbitrary circuits
and notice that in this question there
is no mention to circular security so
there is no need to prove that the
scheme is circular secure in fact the
scheme may not even be
secure and
i'm pretty sure that if you can do this
then you can also modify the
construction to make sure the final
result is not the circular secure just
using uh
some trick
so it is a way to describe the problem
without bringing circular security into
the picture and perhaps it could be
useful uh to get a better understanding
of the difficulties
that behind this open problem of basing
fully homomorphic encryption on standard
assumptions of course if that's not
possible it would be interesting to show
some kind of separation showing for
example that there is no blackboard
construction of the fully composable
homomorphic encryption schemes
from
the traditional homomorphic encryption
schemes so and with this i will conclude
the talk i will skip the approximate
encryption one and we can approximately
go to lunch
after this i'll just show the picture
so i have a question so can you do this
composable thing for a class that's uh
would you get benefit for thinking about
composable homomorphic encryption when
you don't go for the fully so if you
you're restrict uh
yeah you can instead of computations
yeah yeah so you you can use different
classes of functions
and i mean you can pose the problem with
uh so any class of functions that you
close that is closed under composition
you can
apply the definition
you can also apply the definition to a
limited class of functions so that only
supports bounded composition if you like
so the definition yeah can be adapted to
capture all of those things so in terms
of constructions and what you need to
get to the final result so if you solve
the problem assuming circular security
and using boostrapping then
if you have an fh scheme a
non-composable supporting essentially
the decryption function
of the
input of the original scheme
if using that you can build a fully
composable scheme
supporting just additional you know
multiplication or any other set of
operations of your choice then you would
get the full composition a composable
solution
for the type of computations that are
described by those operations
got it thank you
mission
[Music]
um
yeah i have a sort of uh
a funny question about this um
you know
in terms of the role that uh lwe plays
in
uh
fully homomorphic encryption
so
uh i guess one could ask why is it such
a you know why does it play such a big
role and is it the could it possibly be
that the
that the noise which is such a big
problem
is actually the feature that makes it
possible or what what is it that uh
that's really playing this role and how
come this is uh so important in this uh
well i honestly i i don't belie i i
think that noise may not be the correct
intuition i mean that's what has guided
latis cryptography so far but then when
we abstract the problem and we try to
understand oh what is the difficulty
perhaps thinking about noise is not the
right way to go i mean if i give you
there's a code or one of these libraries
implementing the current versions of the
fully homomorphic encryption i mean
go find where and what part of it is
something that can be considered noise
so
we know that encryption is randomized
so that's something that
i mean there's no escape
it has to be randomized then whether
there is something that actually
is noise or not yeah
maybe we should stop thinking about
noise
or me
you're basically asking if perhaps we
should do no we should really think
about noise and understand why noise is
so fundamental to me noise seems
something that is very specific to
lattice cryptography it's something that
we hardly find in most other
mathematical problems used for
cryptography yeah so is is
is there an alternate to uh lwe for for
fully homomorphic encryption then
the noise no no is there is there
another construction which doesn't go
through lwe
no no no no so so this currently so this
stock was just about problems and
definitions i don't have any other
solution to do this but if you achieve
this fully composable homophily
encryption then weather internally is
using something which is noisy or not
that something would be completely
hidden by the definition
so it's the noise sort of disappears at
that level you can do composition in a
way that is uh
fully composable so you know noise is
not something to
to worry about so it would make it
easier to use
but as it is based on what we know so
far i i don't know if it helps to come
up with a different solution but yeah it
was more of a way to get a better handle
on the problem
i